hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast and just check it out on you you
know just seeing how the holidays are
going it's such a weird time you take
time to give thanks to see what's
important in life with all this
craziness going around um anyway uh uh
oh my god
I'm [ __ ] I am underwater right now I
gotta take this [ __ ] test by the end
of the year I think I'm gonna take it
tomorrow and after I do this podcast I'm
just gonna be [ __ ] with my nose in a
goddamn book but I think I'm ready you
know I had there's eight chapters and
there was like three things that I
sucked at the HSI with reverse sensing
which you guys all know about tear drop
parallel and direct entries got that
yeah finally finally I watched this
wonderful person explain it on the
Internet the [ __ ] HSI the second
reverses itself how I do it is just like
well what do I think's happening because
it's the exact opposite and then the RMI
is is just like oh yeah they're like
outdated but you still need to know
about these things it's like fantastic
like did you guys know that when you're
whether you're on the ground or whether
you're airborne if you're checking to vo
ours against each other they can have
only plus or minus four degrees
error or you can't have an IFR flight do
you remember that Fred Flintstone
episode where he went back to college
and he was doing the [ __ ] he was on
the math team and he was on the football
team and he was killing it on the
football team but his workload with the
math stuff and then he started calling
this signals he's like 45 times pi yeah
I can't read it to die dude he just
[ __ ] lost his [ __ ] that's where I
feel I am right now
um so I'm gonna plow through it though
but it is it's [ __ ] fascinating you
know if it just wasn't under the gun you
know if I started this [ __ ] if anybody's
gonna try to get their instrument rating
start in January
go out and get the book you got 12
[ __ ]
laxing months to get it done don't come
out of doing a [ __ ] movie you know
going into the holidays let i do
everything the hardest [ __ ] way
stupid stupid German Irish [ __ ] [ __ ]
there's stairs or there's an elevator
what do you take it's a [ __ ] disease
you know in 2020 what I would like to do
is I'd like to take care of me I'd like
to try to make my life more easier
anyway it's all gonna pay off it's all
kind of payoffs I don't know [ __ ] all
right well I got it I got to do is send
off here to unfortunately another
comrade has passed
Angelo Lazaro who was you know somebody
unfortunately I haven't seen when we saw
a couple times in the last 10 years but
there was a significant and important
part of my career where I saw that guy
four or five times a night for a couple
of years when I was doing all the uptown
rooms which is what the industry would
call the black rooms and he like me used
to do all the rooms which is what I felt
as a comedian you should be able to do
right I didn't want to be like the radio
station like I am funny to people like
males ages 18 to [ __ ] 24 and you know
the [ __ ] northwest hemisphere was
just like just get me in front of a
crowd and I want to be able to [ __ ]
say what I want to say and do well I
learned that in the summer of 86 before
I was ever even a comedian I went to
great woods in Mansfield Massachusetts
which now I don't even know what it's
called
and I saw two comedians that summer I
went I saw Rodney Dangerfield who was
riding high off the success of back to
school and I went I saw him and he was
amazing and he [ __ ] kill
and everybody there left and it never
dawned on me that it was an all-white
crowd until a month later I went and I
saw Eddie Murphy on the rot or Eddie
Murphy who by the way is hosting SNL
this week so you ready mind if you don't
watch that and I saw Eddie Murphy and I
don't know why it was only 18 years old
but I clicked I looked around and I saw
the crowds like this guy is making
everybody laugh there was young old
black white male female he had the whole
[ __ ] place Diane laughing and I don't
know why that just kind of stuck with me
so long story I started doing all of the
rooms once I got the balls up to do it
not gonna lie to you and then and then
doing those I met Angelo and uh [ __ ] I
remember this one time we did this gig
he booked this gig back when Spanish
Harlem was Spanish Harlem it wasn't a
bunch of white people that couldn't
afford to live on double-digit Manhattan
streets anymore you know so he had this
gig up there and it was to raise money
for this school I'm trying to remember
this gig and we go in there and it's at
the school and it was a weird time it
was like on a Sunday at like 5:00 in the
afternoon so it was like me him and I
think Dean Edwards and we were waiting
to for the show to start before we went
on there was this hope they had these
these cute girls right they were like
you know [ __ ] you know doing this
whole dance routine they they couldn't
have been like third graders forks
layers [ __ ] adorable right so they
going up there to do their dance routine
so they put on some sort of like I don't
know what some sort of music and they're
dancing and whatever and it's adorable
and everything and then all of a sudden
you know the breakdown part comes and I
swear to god they started dancing like
adult women in a [ __ ] booty video I
swear to God and I was just like what
the [ __ ] and I looked over at Angelou
and I was just like dude what the [ __ ]
is he I know man
he just cuz they they shouldn't have
dancing like who cheese we just started
[ __ ] we literally turned our back to
the to the performance and we're both
just standing there crying laughing and
then thinking like why is this
acceptable to all the adults here
what the [ __ ] in it's 5:00 in the
afternoon and not only do we have to go
on at a school we got to go on after
[ __ ] you know eight-year-old girls
dancing totally inappropriately so this
show where the show was actually I think
Angela went up there and he [ __ ]
addressed it thank God and he did it in
such a masterful way because the lot of
the parents were there and you know now
being a parent I know what it can what
it's like to even even approach another
parent with hey maybe you're not doing
such a good job in this moment as a
parent not saying you're a bad parent
just you might want to look at this or
something like that like it is such like
you know trying you know just snip the
right wire so it doesn't blow up and he
just went up there
and it was just great because he was art
we were already laughing and then he
went up there still like laughing and
was saying hello and he just seemed like
you know was just in this great [ __ ]
mood and I I remember I just was so
thankful that he did that he was such a
[ __ ] great comedian and it's a huge
loss another another great one goes but
I guess that's how life is you know when
you get to be my age it's not like you
know that's what happens I don't know
what to say so
rest in peace peace Angela Lozado man
what a funny [ __ ]
so speaking of which I had one of my
relatives my grandmother she lived up be
almost 105 one of the most amazing
things about that was she went through
three like generations of friends like
she outlived everyone
her generation the generation behind her
and then the generation after that
because people for the most part start
you know had a more rapid rate somewhere
in your 60s 70s and 80s they go and she
lived north of a hundred so the by the
time she got to her 90s she'd outlive
pretty much everybody in her generation
and the generation behind her and then
she went another [ __ ] 10 years it was
under it's like we she was basically the
Tom Brady of of grandmothers she just
kept going and then if you look actually
if you really want to be accurate he's
Adam Vinatieri he might be older than
Tom Brady but you know he gets the he
gets the they get the asterisk because
they don't have to deal with the contact
you know so I mean that's the way to go
you don't get the [ __ ] Pte you know
all you got to do is just keep one leg
stretchy the other one could be like a
[ __ ] you know you get polio and the
other [ __ ] leg I mean look at one guy
the guy yeah half a [ __ ] forty kicked
at 63 yards you know I'll tell you
people you know if you're playing
football and your dream dies it's your
position don't you could always be a
field goal kicker I really believe that
excuse me for a second sorry that's the
noise I make when I blow my nose anyway
let's plow ahead speaking this week of
that this weekend the premiere matchup
as far as I'm concerned is the New
England Patriots versus the Buffalo
Bills the New England Patriots have
dominated the AFC East for the last 20
years in fact I don't think we've we've
we haven't won the division I think the
Jets wanted like one year during this
entire maybe a couple I don't know I
think well it was like two times maybe
we didn't win the [ __ ] division three
times in 20 [ __ ] years so I would
think as a dolphin fan is a jet fan
anybody in the AFC East other than a
Patriots fan has got to be rooting for
these buff
Bilson what I want to know is are the
Buffalo Bills ready to finally take the
AFC East away from the New England
Patriots are they finally ready to put
dad to bed and say hey it's our time or
are they gonna lose another another
[ __ ] game to Tom Brady and Bill
Belichick you already lost the close one
you lost a close one at home so now you
got to go in there you got to put on
your big-boy pants
okay you got to wipe the Buffalo Wild
Wings sauce off your face okay you got
to go out to Dad's house challenge and
you got to find a way to come away with
a victory is that going to happen or is
your franchise gonna continue to be
known as the wide right faceplant
cardboard table [ __ ] breaking fans
whatever the [ __ ] it is they're doing
out there
the Mick Foley wannabe fan base is that
what your franchise is gonna be I mean
the reality is is there's no [ __ ]
economic reason the City of Buffalo
should have a [ __ ] sports team a
professional level sports team they
shouldn't you know they had them in the
past right who they are they're the
Buffalo those at the Braves what do they
have they're the basketball team they
[ __ ] left became the Cincinnati
Royals I think and then they became the
[ __ ] Sacramento Kings something like
that I don't remember
you know Buffalo had its time during
Prohibition okay and then it just became
another Rust Belt city and every other
sports franchise left it was along one
other one but the Buffalo Bills hung
around and those people in Buffalo they
loved that team because they hung around
but the sad thing is is they think they
that they hung around because
they love those people but I'm here to
tell you the real reason the Buffalo
Bills are still in Buffalo not because
they love the people a buffalo they are
there simply because nobody else wants
them there you go and I hate to tell you
this you're gonna go into Gillette
Stadium and they're gonna take out one
of those razors and they're gonna shave
your bare ass and they're gonna send you
right back to Buffalo with the [ __ ]
loss and there's not enough wings in
your [ __ ] City that's gonna make a
difference I gotta be honest with you I
have no [ __ ] idea what's gonna happen
there was the first game was great and
we have had problems with upper tier
teams this year as far as like none of
the games have been easy and we've we
lost two big ones a couple of big ones
didn't we lost two of the Chiefs and we
lost to [ __ ] the Ravens and we had a
real close one against the bills the
first time so who knows what's gonna
happen I don't know anyway still
sticking by my picks the Ravens versus
the Seattle Seahawks Seattle Seahawks
old Sneaky Pete Carroll wins his second
ring in my heart of hearts that's what I
believe all right it's time to read a
little bit of advertising shall we oh by
the way I was down the comedy stool last
night because I'm getting ready for my
big show in Las Vegas what about what's
up with Trump
dddd talk about your dick at the dad-dad
[ __ ] showgirls that smoke a cigar I
got that show coming up on say night the
[ __ ] is this goddamn thing just never
accepts my podcast
it just doesn't [ __ ] like me come on
I'm sitting here trying to kill [ __ ]
time sing a goddamn Bullwinkle songs and
what do you do what do you do you make
me [ __ ] type it in twice that could
have been a seamless transition all
right so I was down the I was down the
comedy still last night
funny after said one of those welcome
home as I pulled in I was like ah man I
wish I you know I really love to hang
with Rogan the second I thought that
it's like five seconds they I've walking
in the club and he's on stage we had
this great hang shooting the [ __ ] like
the [ __ ] old days hanging out in the
parking lot and everything and I went up
tried some new [ __ ] went okay sort of
yelled my way through my act and then I
went to the the original room where the
magic is and I went up there and [ __ ]
rift on this [ __ ] subject it I don't
know what is about that room it just it
just keeps giving and giving and giving
and he just blows something out and I
felt like I got like this I'll probably
[ __ ] it up when I'm in tonight when I go
down there maybe or if I don't Friday
night I'll probably get out Friday know
probably [ __ ] it up no one meet but uh
just a [ __ ] great hang I love that
goddamn place um speaking of that and
then it went home later on that night
you know what I'd you know what I
finally saw that I've been wanted to see
the second it came up because I'm a
child of the 80s I saw the Rambo movie
last blood okay right now if you're from
my generation that is a must
[ __ ] see absolutely love that movie
there's not an ounce of fat on it it is
exactly what you think it is a Rambo
[ __ ] movie the man is not to be [ __ ]
with if you [ __ ] with him I don't care
how many people are on your side you're
gonna [ __ ] lose one of the most
satisfying movies I've watched in a long
time I want ice put it on at 1:00 in the
morning I didn't even false you know
usually I put a movie on that late I'm
gonna fall asleep I'm an old man I just
sat there loved every [ __ ] frame of
it so two freckled thumbs up last blood
it is a Rambo movie okay if you're a
part of the Rambo franchise you know
what that means you know what to expect
and they [ __ ] give it to you it's
[ __ ] tremendous alright and I know
something's we all really you trying to
compare it to Chariots of Fire
I'm not alright
okay plowing ahead let's let's do a
little bit of the reads here definitely
check it out it's just [ __ ] you know
the guy knows how to make a movie it's
like 90 minutes
bam bam boom done
leaves you wanting more all right
butcher box everybody they hang on a
second jesus [ __ ] christ goddamn
lingering cold like this is like a bowl
like that it like two weeks waiting for
like [ __ ] brain matter to come out
sorry all right
butcher box everybody you know not
everyone has convenient access to
high-quality meat luckily there's
butcher box oh is that what's starving
people around the world can do you just
call butcher box butcher box believes
everyone deserves high-quality meat
humanely high-quality humanely sourced
me every I know what the dead Joe's
probably talking about the United States
that's how crazy our food is now you
know you going out of the goddamn
grocery store you don't know what you're
getting all kinds of dies and all kinds
of see like Jesus Christ you know your
neighbors missing it might be me a
[ __ ] pork chop out Jesus bill every
month butcher bucks ships a curated
selection of high-quality meat right to
your home all the meat is free of
antibiotics and added hormones each box
has nine to eleven pounds of Falken me
enough for 24 individual meals you know
or six you know if you're a competitive
eater or a fat [ __ ] over I've packed
fresh and shipped frozen and vacuum
sealed so it stays that way I can
customize my box I'll go with one of
their other or one of theirs you know in
the future I'll be wrote or I'll be up
he have the exact same line of copy for
a robot sex doll what do I love about my
robot sex doll while I can customize my
box anyways or go with one of theirs
either way I get exactly what I want
it's the best made ship right to my dua
which means one less trip to the
grocer's alright my favorite is a
heritage breed pork
it's unbelievable it's the best pork
shop I've ever had in my house you know
other than one time I went out there was
some celebrity chef wearing clogs who
just [ __ ] crushed it okay but if I
could take his skill set with the
quality of meat that you get from
butcher bucks I wouldn't even have to go
to that goddamn restaurant I would not
have to valet I would not have to get
all dolled up okay you know bring my
wife down there and spend hundreds of
dollars I could eat like that in my own
home
options like a hundred percent grass-fed
grass-fed and finished beef free-range
organic chicken heritage breed pause
ASIS heritage pork what happened to the
breed yeah
it's like the old George Carlin bit
Sears what happened to Roebuck you got
bought out all right wild caught Alaskan
salmon and sugar slash nitrate free
bacon the [ __ ] is a nitrate butcher box
is the most affordable and convenient
way to get healthy humanely raised meat
with butcher blocks you get the highest
quality meat for around for just six
dollars a meal right now you can get two
pounds of salmon absolutely free plus
$20 off your butcher bucks just go to
butcher box com slash / or use promo
code bar at checkout
that's butcher box com / burrow or use
promo code bur at checkout simply safe I
want to remind my listeners time's
running out on simply safes huge holiday
offer it's their biggest sale of the
year if you're looking to fully protect
your home with the award-winning 24/7
home security now's the time to do it
all you friggin rednecks out there with
your ar-15 s okay I don't give a [ __ ]
how many guns you have you need eight
hours sleep okay cuz next thing you know
you're putting on your overalls and
you're buckling them the wrong [ __ ]
way and then everybody thinks you're
something and then you got a [ __ ]
problem if you look at it fully protect
your home with an award-winning 24/7
home security now is the time to do it
Burger Lee's spike during the holiday
season you
with hot with families traveling and
leaving empty homes and expensive gifts
behind why would you do that simply
saves holiday sale couldn't come at a
better time why would you leave the
expensive gifts behind aren't you taking
them to the people or these the gifts
that you got it's confusing copy simply
safe has everything you need to protect
your home and family there's a smart
lock and video doorbell Pro to defend
your front door well I mean you've
alarmed it you're not really defending
your front door you just have some guy
in the video hey no I said stop doing
that an army of sensors and cameras that
guard every window door and room in your
home if there's a break-in they can give
real time video confirmation to police
as it happens that's hilarious then they
pull up attention you in the red shirt
we know you're in the house and we know
you're in the bathroom put the panties
down stop jerking off surrender yourself
so police respond up to 3.5 times faster
no surprise simply no surprise simply
safe has one CNET and PC magazine's
editor Choice Awards I'm surprised I
didn't know they did that they've really
come a long way since I first met him
simply safe made a holiday offer to our
listeners in mind with our listeners in
mind but it ends December 31st they
rarely do deals this big so now's your
chance visit simply safecom / / to find
out just how much you'll save and
remember this sale ends December 31st go
today simply fade simply save si MP Li
safecom / / all right there we go where
are we where are we unfortunately people
I'm gonna have to spend the next seven
minutes of this podcast reviewing it for
my test I'm [ __ ] with you I'm not
gonna do that to you why would I do that
to you would you like to hear some
questions here wind shear where does
wind shear occur a exclusively in
thunderstorms
B whenever there is an abrupt decrease
in pressure and/or temperature C with a
wind shift or a wind speed gradient at
any level in the atmosphere C with
either a wind shift
or a wind speed gradient and any level
in the atmosphere I share may be
associated with either one chef they're
always yeah I'm gonna get that one right
tomorrow
whoo I'm feeling good man feeling
confident got my e6b I'm ready to
[ __ ] do it all right let's talk about
some other [ __ ] okay as much as I loved
last blood I did watch a movie that a
lot of people loved that I absolutely
[ __ ] hated and felt like it was
slapping me in the face thinking I was
stupid the entire time I [ __ ] watched
it you ever hate a [ __ ] I'm not gonna
say the movie alright I'm not gonna say
what movie it is cuz I don't want to
ruin your [ __ ] I might be wrong okay
I've never in my you ever [ __ ] just
hate a [ __ ] movie so but you hate it
so much you need to find somebody else
that also hate like me am I out of my
[ __ ] mind
all my falkland gone this movie had me
pacing I hated it so much so I literally
had to reach out to like three different
[ __ ] friends of mine and none of them
have seen it none of them like [ __ ]
up there then they just like oh yeah I
didn't see it yeah I you didn't like it
I just thought and then I gotta like
bring it all the way down i watch sports
I just totally walk it back down oh my
god Jesus Christ this thing had me
[ __ ] walking around trying to think
let me pick one from a long [ __ ] time
ago senator anybody's [ __ ] feelings
out here trying to think of a [ __ ]
movie that everybody loved
ah Jesus I'm the course nothing's coming
to me well if it had it been one of
these [ __ ] thing I don't know you
know what one of the worst things you
can do as an older guys try to remember
[ __ ]
anyway
anybody who sees me in Vegas you're
gonna get one to two shows you're either
gonna see me over the moon happy that I
passed this [ __ ] test or over the
moon [ __ ] funny because I flunked it
I don't think I'm gonna no no I wouldn't
I'm a professional I would never do that
to you I would never do that to you but
I'm gonna tell you right now I'm having
a hard time finishing this podcast cuz
I'm just looking at those two text books
going like I need to be [ __ ] looking
at those things but I already know I
already I know I know all of the [ __ ]
chapters I just got to [ __ ] get that
HSI thing down today the reverse sensing
and I just have to I got to do the
teardrop parallel direct entry in the
RMI [ __ ] like [ __ ] a hundred times
and I'll have that [ __ ] down and then
I'm gonna walk in there with a sharpened
pencil and I'm gonna do some [ __ ]
damage alright
I haven't played drums in a month I've
just [ __ ] just been like [ __ ]
everything else other than my family I
am gonna get I [ __ ] I gotta get this
thing done and this is gonna open up a
whole new world for me Oh Billy in the
clouds his brain is already up there you
know what's funny is I initially
resented the test because so much of it
is about fixed wing which is airplanes
and not enough about rotorcraft which is
helicopters and I have to know all of
their [ __ ] but they don't have to know
any of my [ __ ] so with each chapter
it ends with like an extra [ __ ] six
[ __ ] questions or a page or two or
whatever of questions you know just for
people who fly helicopters but I still
have to know their [ __ ] they don't have
to know my [ __ ] you know I mean and
that's not a big deal one chapter but
there's eight chapters it's like an
extra [ __ ] 5060 [ __ ] questions and
what I want to know is why whenever I
get on the seesaw of life am I always
the one holding the other [ __ ] person
up you know what I mean if you look at
the [ __ ] male-female dynamic course I
do you know why a fish
look at look at the whole [ __ ] look
at this whole [ __ ] holiday [ __ ]
horseshit how much money do you gotta
spend how much money is she gonna spend
huh is there a [ __ ] Rodeo Drive that
a woman has to walk down
is there a street like that in the
[ __ ] world sat a [ __ ] 5th Avenue
in New York is there a [ __ ] Street in
the world like that that a woman has to
walk down going like jesus [ __ ]
christ how much is this gonna cost me
but I got to do it cuz maybe maybe this
will make him happy going down by and
like a [ __ ] diamond encrusted [ __ ]
barbecue and Grill [ __ ]
limited-edition Louie Vuitton hibachi
with monogrammed of spatula anyway I am
excited about the holidays you know Oh
Billy no booze by the way I've almost
done it I wanted to go January 1st to
December 31st I want to go home calendar
year without any [ __ ] booze that's
what I would love to do
okay what's today's date huh I don't
even know what today's date is I know
21st is my show so today's the 19th
there's 31 days 31 minus 19 well Jesus
Christ that's gotta be 12 I'm 12 days
away from achieving that and I know you
guys are all on the edge of your seats
you're not bored of listening to me talk
about this I know you're not I know it's
just as exciting he's not more exciting
for you the listener so I'll do that and
then I think I want to go I want to go
home like a year of my life
birthday life like I haven't drank since
I was 50 I'm now 51 I turned 52 in June
so now I got to go to June right then if
I go to June you know in July I'll be
approaching 600 days I got to make 600
and then I got to go 700 right and then
I got to go a thousand who knows I don't
[ __ ] know I don't know I don't know
what I'm gonna do with this [ __ ] I can't
tell you this I'm a big I'm a big fan of
[ __ ] eggnog and it has been really
difficult to not [ __ ] put brandy in
the
this year you know you get the fire
going you're watching last blood you got
the tree on you got your eggnog come on
by the way my [ __ ] humidors [ __ ]
bursting with cigars Jesus Christ it was
empty
I was out holidays came and everybody
got me these amazing amazing boxes of
cigars I can't do that so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna have in in January I
don't have like three days where I have
like ten friends over that all [ __ ]
smoke you know then I gotta cuz I got
like 30 cigars it'll just be gone then
all I do is smoke three of them that's
it because now I do the bill Bert
podcast once a month with the absolute
force of nature juggernaut that is Bert
Kreischer and I gotta tell you I don't
want to give away the January episode
but I smoked a cigar in that one with
him
that I almost had to go to the [ __ ]
emergency room afterwards like I was not
right like I limped out to the [ __ ]
car it was enough to back Oh for [ __ ]
six months but that's part of the
podcast you know we smoked a big
ridiculous stupid [ __ ] cigar each
time maybe next time we'll go
ridiculously small I love how we feel
like we have to do something ridiculous
with the cigar like the two of us and
the way we think isn't ridiculous and
sad enough that we have to do this [ __ ]
so I don't know who knows anyway where
am I here I'm gonna upload this [ __ ]
thing oh Jesus I did it next a couple of
minutes there anyways it's the end of
the year this is the time of year where
you reflect you try to become a better
person you give people thank you and I
want to thank all you guys for coming
out to my shows watching f is for family
listening to the podcast
dealing with me coughing on the podcast
all the kind words about the Mandalorian
there and all you people in Buffalo with
a good sense of humor it's gonna be a
great game good luck to you guys good
luck go pats of course I'm root for the
Patriots and it [ __ ] Bruins keep
losing Jesus Christ that's good it's
good to lose now not that rather than
later I was watching last night I was
watching Edmonton I watched the first
the first period of edmonton oilers
against the st. Louis Blues and I can't
believe how much I [ __ ] hate the
Blues it's ridiculous I used to love
that [ __ ] team i brewed for Saint
Louis because I want to see them get a
cup and just you know it was a hit in
the first period where this guy [ __ ]
went down and the whole crowd booing I
was literally screaming at my TV going
that's how you won a Cup the [ __ ] are
you booing about and then I saw the
replay it was a totally clean [ __ ]
hit to the point I thought that guy was
faking it anyways I think you know in
2020 I will let go of that [ __ ]
heartbreak in game seven loss but if I
keep talking about I know people in st.
Louis will they'll enjoy it so who knows
who gives a [ __ ] alright that's the
podcast please listen to this music and
and then there's gonna be a Greatest
Hits Thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday morning podcast afterwards
another 30 minutes from a Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
morning podcasts that I did I don't know
a couple years ago a couple months ago I
don't know how it works all right god
bless you go [ __ ] yourself have a great
weekend you guys hey what's going on
it's Bill Byrne it's the Monday morning
podcast from Monday December 19 2011
2011 what's going on how are you did you
get your holiday shopping done oh my
[Music]
what are you gonna get her and and a
better question why are you gonna get
her something huh why you guys falling
into this [ __ ] [ __ ] why can't you be
independent [ __ ] thinker like myself I
haven't bought anybody [ __ ] this year
I'm just cuz I haven't had time to so
now I have to go where I don't want to
go I have to go out into the malls today
the second I'm done with this
[ __ ] podcast I gotta go out to
the malls I gotta go out there and look
at the people with their fat [ __ ]
stretchy pants you know those big giant
plastic bags of [ __ ] for what you know
this is a question I have for you if you
know I have a couple you know I got
nieces and nephews
I'll buy [ __ ] for them you know but
there's got to be some sort of like just
cutoff age you know like I don't know
thirteen once you're 13 it's like you
know [ __ ] grow up there all these
people in my life they're in their 30s
and 40s I'm sitting there going you know
what what do they want for Christmas
we're my gonna get you a bicycle you
know you can't [ __ ] believe what
somebody asked me for somebody older
just got married they asked me to get
him a panini press go get it yourself
[ __ ]
[ __ ] even so one of those all right down
there at the douche store supposed to go
down there aprons are us I don't even
know where they sell one of those
[ __ ] things give me a [ __ ] panini
president what kills me is they live
like three states away
it's like [ __ ] mailing a pile of
bricks goddamn post is just gonna cost
more than the [ __ ] penny anything I'd
really like a toaster Wolff don't buy
what that's one of the worst is when
people ask you for non exciting gifts
it's either completely non exciting or
it's something down there at that
[ __ ] dead [ __ ] store [ __ ] I store
Apple store the Apple store everybody
wants something from there
I can give me and I can oh you mean that
thing that's not quite a laptop that's
what you want which is eventually gonna
be a laptop in six months that's what
you want you want one of those just so
you can be scrolling around on the plane
so you can keep up with the other [ __ ]
you know it's so six months from now
when they come out with the better one
that's almost a laptop but not quite
there then you're gonna want that one
for your birthday listen to me [ __ ]
moaning and complaining like I'm not
good like I'm not gonna go right the
[ __ ] down there and go do it [ __ ] I
gotta blow my nose hang on a second all
right I'm back I know what you think it
bill I thought it was just a cold you're
still sick what do you got when he got a
bola no I don't I just been on the road
been on the road for three [ __ ] weeks
three weeks straight isn't a spider it's
a dead spider you know I don't [ __ ] with
spiders you know I look at them as a
necessary part of nature when I have a
spider when I bite into a york
peppermint pattie when I when I have a
spider in my house I just I let I
[ __ ] let it do it do its thing kills
bugs right where'd you rather have a
dead spider in 20 bugs or just one fat
spider hanging in the corner that's how
I look at it I mean you know I don't
like any of them I don't want any of
them in my house but if I had to choose
I sound like a racist right now you know
talking about my neighborhood except I'm
talking about bugs me tell you right now
I'd rather have one of them [ __ ]
spiders than ten of them goddamn flies
god damn flies ruin the [ __ ]
neighborhood since those [ __ ] flies
moved in buzzing all over the place with
their [ __ ] music anyway so this is
the Monday morning podcast and this is
this one of the last ones of the year I
believe has got to be well there's one
more fizz one more Monday and so this is
Monday and what have you done that I
[ __ ]
that song all the Christmas songs put
you in a good mood you know but but
it'll pop up right except for silver
bells silver bells just you know takes
money you know if I was a fighter you
know what a fighter loses its legs loses
his legs and he just ski just can't even
[ __ ] he's got no gas left that's what
silver bells does to me silver bells and
you know my God if they gonna pick up
the tempo maybe they're gonna pick up
the tempo
you know there's a few songs out there
that make me hate being white and that's
one of them you know other than that you
know pretty cool being white it's a good
[ __ ] gig you know another time that
you just really I don't know that I find
that I hate white people is when I
listen to Ray Charles version of that
song Georgia you know and I and the
songs [ __ ] amazing it gives me chills
how great he sings this song and then
right in the middle of it these [ __ ]
three white [ __ ] and I could say that
cuz I'm white
they come in and they just ruined the
[ __ ] song with their background
singing you know he's hours reach out to
me I don't put her in it
something-something smile tenderly you
all right
something like that and these [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the background they go George
right in the middle of it why would you
do that you might as well have just
dropped my version of red Charles
singing and singing that song right in
there they absolutely ruined that song I
remember back in the day when I had this
piece of [ __ ] for [ __ ] 83 Ford Ranger
2 wheel drive long bed factory wheels
and hubcaps big neon sign saying please
don't [ __ ] me blinking on and off
in front of the windshield a little bit
of rust on the passenger side door and I
when I used to listen to that on
cassette you know cuz that was happening
just like Patrick Swayze in the
beginning of [ __ ] that movie made
about being a bouncer at the Roadhouse
right I used to listen to that [ __ ]
song and right before those [ __ ]
goddamn Whitey's would start singing I
would turn it down and I would just
count 3 1000 and then I would turn it
back up so all I heard was Rey you know
I heard that Ray Charles was notoriously
difficult and when you know and you
start to believe that [ __ ] but then when
you listen that recording it's like yeah
obviously why would he be difficult
because he had to go to those studios
and [ __ ] people would do [ __ ] like
that to his songs do you think I'm
exaggerating by the way that that's the
way they sing it you know what if that's
what you think you [ __ ] because
it's Christmas and what have you done
[ __ ] you John Lennon what the [ __ ] have
you done
why don't you come back when you got
that goddamn [ __ ] in line she's [ __ ]
up all the recordings she can't sing she
can't play anything she's in the [ __ ]
way
we get it you like [ __ ] her do it at
home sorry I put that [ __ ] song right
up there that Phil Colin singing about
the homeless do they know they're
homeless how the [ __ ] does that song go
why the [ __ ] did that wait a [ __ ] do you
get off owning a castle talking to me
telling me to remember the homeless
huh why don't you remember the homeless
next time you have enough threesome
while someone's doing a [ __ ] keyboard
solo and you're keeping 80% of the door
and [ __ ] paying that guy is a hired
gun
alright there forever balding who took
longer to go bald him or Jack Nicholson
how much say Jack Nicholas every time
all right what am I looking up here
let's go on YouTube all right just for
all you people out there who think I'm
self-hating here because I'm trash and
white people
I'm not trashing it straight across the
board okay I went to Arizona and back in
like [ __ ] round trip like two hours
thanks to white people you know and
their [ __ ] airplanes um anyways what
am I doing here what am i let's see if
we go Ray Charles Ray Charles
I gotta type with one index finger cuz
I'm holding under the microphone you
know what's [ __ ] up you know the day
you become a man I'm more of a man more
of a disgusting less refined man it's
the first time you blow your nose
without Kleenex you know like you're
running a marathon or something you just
do that
it's [ __ ] unreal it's scary the first
time you do it you know you're like
where exactly is this gonna go alright
how the [ __ ] do you spell Georgia I
don't know how to spell Georgia I
spelled to GE o RG I a that can't be
right
I've been to that state come on
oh there we go that is how you spell it
alright Georgia on my mind is this gonna
be it it's just the original one it's
just live I [ __ ] this I gotta hit
pause I gotta hit pause alright I can't
find the [ __ ] thing all they got is
live versions all over the place you
know ah whatever what are you gonna do
you know what I'm saying
they [ __ ] ruin it and then I went and
I go on YouTube when I try and figure
out what the where the [ __ ] it is and
and I can't find it and I just killed my
entire flow nice going bill nice [ __ ]
going what was i doing Oh screaming
about John Lennon oh this has got to be
frustrating to you guys as listeners
really I was talking about blowing my
nose speaking of which you know I just
took my dog out and I just [ __ ]
seriously why am I talking about blowing
your nose without Kleenex all right now
that I've lost all the female listeners
let's talk about something here then
absolutely [ __ ] and enrages me as
opposed to everything else that keeps me
so nice and [ __ ] calm somebody sent
me a story this is
un-fuckin'-believable some guy goes to
jail all right
for rape listen this a man who spent 25
years in prison for a crime he did not
commit all right he went to jail for uh
for the rape of some woman and in 2008
after DNA proved he could not have been
the attacker he was awarded four million
dollars compensation that's what he got
four million dollars well you know and
and sex offenders get treated the worst
in prison all right so that guy you know
let's just say it was just some regular
dude he's like a [ __ ] you know
construction worker maybe took a couple
of karate classes whatever now he's in
[ __ ] Thunderdome people want to beat
him down somebody's gonna try to rape on
myself we've all seen Shawshank
Redemption this is what this guy went
through for 25 [ __ ] years and he
didn't even do it didn't even [ __ ] do
it so they give the guy for a million
dollars he you know something those
piece-of-shit banker [ __ ] are
gonna come in and tax him and hit him
for half of that you know that should be
tax [ __ ] free but here's where it gets
worse all right the guy faces a court
battle to keep hold of the money he was
awarded for his wrongful conviction
[Music]
because now his ex-wife who divorced him
three years into his life sentence has
taken him to court in a bid to get a
share of the four million dollar
compensation she claims he owes her the
money that she would have been entitled
to had they divorced and shared their
assets can you [ __ ] believe this [ __ ]
this guy went to jail for the worst
[ __ ] crime alright one of them it's
got to be up there if you want to
[ __ ] argue about it right he didn't
even do it he's sitting there going
honey I didn't do this you got to stick
by my side she hangs in there for three
years go [ __ ] yourself
I'm out of here what do you think she's
been doing for the last [ __ ] twenty
two years as far as I can tell
besides not working on a career she's
been out there sucking a whole bunch of
other dicks that's what she's been doing
so now it turns out that this
[ __ ] didn't do it okay if she
stuck by his [ __ ] side stop by his
[ __ ] side this right here is a
Hollywood movie but she [ __ ] left
alright
she left until her stank and puss smelt
all that [ __ ] money all right and
this is what I want to know why is it
this [ __ ] show on the view right now
on one of those shows with all the way
why isn't it on those shows why do they
constantly show only guys doing [ __ ] to
women you know I get it
some [ __ ] psycho throws acid on his
ex-girlfriend you got to expose that guy
you got to teach people about that [ __ ]
but how about a little bit of fair and
balanced reporting you think they're
gonna go after this [ __ ] thing you
think if those [ __ ] [ __ ] saw this
story in the green room you think they'd
be like you know what maybe we should
talk about this they're never talking
about [ __ ] like this all they do is talk
about when bad [ __ ] happens to women and
if you if I'd like this [ __ ] here that
I'm talking about would come off as
[ __ ] misogynistic hatred towards
women it's unreal well you're taking
this isolated this isolated incident and
then you know I'm not this isn't an
isolated incident Sugar Shane Mosley's
getting a divorce one of the greatest
boxers of all time his ex-wife not only
taken his [ __ ] money all right she
wants the championship belts to and she
was awarded them this kind of [ __ ]
happens all the [ __ ] time
un-fuckin'-believable can you fight and
I'll tell you what the funny thing is
she's gonna get some money
she'll get money out of it the same way
you hold the door for him they don't pay
for their [ __ ] drinks they turn
around and get hammered throw a drink in
your face and then the bouncer puts you
in a chokehold drags you up and then you
go to court for disturbing the [ __ ]
peace and what the [ __ ] does she do
she's she's in there feeling justified
wondering if you know she has a lawsuit
against you because she dislocated her
elbow when she threw a beer bottle at
your [ __ ] head
un-fuckin'-believable I swear to God if
I could do life over again I would be a
judge you know and I would have a whole
briefcase full of hammers because by the
end of the day I would throw them at so
many of these [ __ ] [ __ ] heads you
know you know I couldn't then I would
just be he hates women I would be
disbarred within two seconds I would
love to be a judge lady you might be the
most if I could throw someone in prison
for being an absolutely reprehensible
incurable [ __ ] money-grubbing [ __ ]
it would be you but I can't the law does
not allow me so why don't you do me a
favor in a room full of perverts and
scumbags you are the worst so get out of
my [ __ ] courtroom and make it a
little cleaner you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
I don't know this is even funny anymore
this is just absolutely [ __ ]
ridiculous and what's even more
is the lack of national exposure a story
like that's gonna get so you know what
so let's keep a tally shall we will
start with the Sugar Shane Mosley
something you know he's going through a
divorce she also has to get the [ __ ]
championship belts you know why cuz they
match your [ __ ] shoes or because it's
a vindictive move and she's trying to
break a man you know we'll go with like
the lighter ones Kobe Bryant's getting a
divorce
okay he's worth three hundred and eighty
million that means his [ __ ] wife is
gonna get a hundred ninety million
probably can't hit a layup on a [ __ ]
nerf hoop set you know and a bunch of
broads will be like yeah she's entitled
to it she supported him
un-fuckin'-believable just robbing these
guys [ __ ] blind what about that
goddamn yellow diamond he bought her why
don't you go take that down to a pawn
shop and live off that for the rest of
your [ __ ] life all right they have
ringless un-fuckin'-believable
how many more men are gonna get sliced
in half with these [ __ ] it's
unbelievable un-fuckin'-believable and
they don't do any stories about it and
when you bring it up low you know he
shouldn't have married her
yeah she should have ducked what if I
said that right that I'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
bill where did the Christmas go where
did what happened to the holidays
Georgia [ __ ] I can't believe I gotta go
Christmas shopping unbelievable alright
so there you go if you want to look up
that story we actually got that story
from a great website called barstool
sports it's all Boston [ __ ] so just a
warning if your sports fan of other
sports but you know they do have stories
like this all right the guys name
Stephen Phillips his ex-wife is named
Tracy trucker what a [ __ ] dude that is
first-ballot Hall of Fame [ __ ]
right there no question
waving the five year rule you're going
right in
oh speaking of sports technically I'm
not allowed to talk about them this week
not even technically literally I'm not
allowed to because the pool I'm in with
Paul virzi you know we picked four games
a week end of the year whoever you know
that's the best record you win a hundred
bucks it's no big deal if you go for no
the other guy owes you 25 bucks you know
that's called the unimaginable if you go
oh and four that's called the
unthinkable I have never done the
unthinkable Mercy's done it twice I've
gone for know twice Versys never done it
but if you gamble long enough this [ __ ]
hits the fan and this week I did the
unthinkable practically the impossible
I've been on four games and did not only
did I not beat the spread on one of them
none of my teams even won the [ __ ]
game granted it was a crazy week with
the cheetah Chiefs beating the Packers
and the Colts finally winning and Jesus
finally not taking Tim Tebow's phone
calls you know it was it was definitely
a weird week but still how does one go
oh and for I it's an absolute [ __ ]
embarrassment so this is the thing I was
up six and a half games on virzi with 12
to go all right and he said before
yesterday started he goes what I need is
an absolute September 2011 Red Sox
collapse out of you so what do I do I go
oh in four I try to help the guy out but
what does Paul virzi do how does he
respond he went oh and three he went oh
in [ __ ] three so tonight who does he
got he took the 49ers given three all
right so on a week when I did the
unthinkable
I went oh and four he could actually
pick up four games all right he could
have picked up four [ __ ] games
it'd only been two out and just had an
unbelievable [ __ ] comeback what does
he do he goes on three worse I can do is
lose a game lose a game I'll be up five
with eight to go
what's wrong with what is wrong I want
you guys to ask Paul virzi you know what
is what is he waiting for he has a fear
of success this is why picked if you
were interested
I took the [ __ ] Green Bay Packers and
I'm not [ __ ] with the Chiefs anymore
if I bet on him they don't show up if I
bet against them they're world beaters
so I took the [ __ ] Green Bay Packers
I took the Giants at home playing the
Redskins they're playing for the
playoffs
Redskins got nothing to lose and they
got rex grossman anything beyond 17
yards he's throwing it up for grabs
given five and a half no biggie I'll
take the Giants is a [ __ ] win they
get their asses kicked then this is the
only dumb one I had you know I didn't
even look I didn't even realize the
Bears starting quarterback wasn't
playing you know and I was like the
Bears got a good defense I think Pete
Carroll's a [ __ ] or maybe it's just cuz
he wears those Dockers I say the Bears
think the Bears are gonna cover I didn't
realize that their starting quarterback
wasn't it not to say that the starting
quarterback wasn't it I would have taken
Seattle but I want to stay away from
that game you know [ __ ] Panthers have
been making me money for [ __ ] weeks
stay away from those guys they come in
and kick the [ __ ] out of them and then
finally I had to pick between the Ravens
in the the San Diego Chargers you know
and who knows what the [ __ ] the Chargers
are they this team are they that team
and I'm like whatever the Ravens are
consistently a good defensive team I'm
gonna take these guys
Joe Flacco whatever maybe he'll get
something done so I take the [ __ ]
Ravens and they get raped [ __ ] raped
who the [ __ ] did virzi take first he
took Tim Tebow and Jesus to be Tom Brady
and
seyton Bill Belichick or at least some
people consider him Satan and you know
devil always wins on earth people I
don't know if you realize that so he
lost that one
he took the Jets they got raped who else
did he take it's somebody else in there
oh he had to [ __ ] he had the Arizona
Cardinals playing the Browns given six I
was actually at that game I went to that
that's a legendary Stadium that's where
the [ __ ] undefeated Patriots lost to
Eli Manning who I was convinced was
gonna make the playoffs and go on
another run and beat the undefeated
Packers in Green Bay and then go on to
win another Super Bowl and he would be
bigger than Joe Namath in New York and
bigger than his brother at home that's
what I thought was gonna happen and now
I don't even [ __ ] know so who knows
so I'm hoping tonight first he goes oh
and four and I'm gonna [ __ ] laugh my
ass off wipe my brow and then you know
it's funny I didn't even win one game
and my magic number will be down to
[ __ ] two at that point so that'll be
two years in a row that I beat for so
don't don't email virgin see this week
wait till I win you know if I win at
this point Jesus Christ oh and four so I
can't talk anymore sports this week you
know all I will say is that Tim Tebow
looks like the lead singer of that dude
in Mumford and Sons
a better he's in better shape and way
less annoying I don't like that guy
stomping around you know quit stomping
your [ __ ] foot to knowing anyways
alright diet tip hello bill hello bill
I've been hearing you [ __ ] about
staying in shape and eating right for a
while now and I thought it could help
you out good dude I'll take any any help
you got you know in order to eat right
you don't have to eat like a [ __ ]
oatmeal and whatnot why is oatmeal
eating like a [ __ ] oh my god he's gonna
go old school real men eat barbeque
though you shove a
khau up your ass that's right and then
you have cancer and then you [ __ ] die
when you're 50
like [ __ ] Vince Lombardi you'll be
one of those guys with this short sleeve
dress shirt guy do tell me how to tell
me how to die like they did in the 1940s
here we go what I'm saying is I've found
a way to eat awesome [ __ ] and stay in
shape
it's called intermittent fasting or lean
gains don't you love that he said I'm
eating like a [ __ ] all right and then
he's gonna say and now he eats like a
supermodel this is a supermodel diet
yeah I know you go you go and you get
eat [ __ ] barbecue and then you go
puke behind a dumpster or you just sit
there and you don't eat you know like
one of those big raccoon I [ __ ] the
[ __ ] that disease called anorexic
girls you know those little skeletal
girls okay so what do I have to do
basically what you do is create an eight
hours fasting window and when I say
fasting I mean Oh feasting window when I
say feasting I mean eating like a
monster and sixteen hours of fasting you
can drink diet soda or coffee or tea
without sugar water and stuff in the
sixteen hour window of fasting yeah
Jesus if you're registered check this
website lean Gamescom and has lots of
info anyways the podcast is awesome you
love this [ __ ] he's just trying to help
me out but you started it dude you
called me a [ __ ] and you know me I'm
defensive I'm always gonna [ __ ] react
why is he nobody [ __ ] well that's not
a [ __ ] move you know it's a [ __ ] move
if you get it if you make oatmeal and
then you put brown sugar in it and some
blueberries and all that type of [ __ ]
I just [ __ ] throw it in the bowl I
eat like a goddamn [ __ ] prisoner of
war that's how I start my day I don't
know you know what I've actually read
some [ __ ] about fasting that's actually
good for your digestive tract to give it
a break you know most people just called
eight hours of sleep but I heard it's
actually good you kind of give
everything else a rest but uh
your digestive tract just kind of like
it's got like the subways in New York
you know I mean the trains run less
frequently at night if you know what I'm
saying
disgusting um wait this guy's from
Macedonia and he goes oh yeah I speak
better English than you of course you do
it's cuz we have a [ __ ] better
economy if you guys had nuclear weapons
and a good economy our economy sucks I
would speak Macedonian you know really
sick of these [ __ ] [ __ ] who think
they're absolutely brilliant because
they can speak more than one language
you know what I mean
it's really not that [ __ ] impressive
you know if you if you're in if you live
in America and you learn to speak more
than one language that's [ __ ]
impressive because you don't need to you
you learn to speak [ __ ] English
because you had to you think I'm sitting
around listening to any podcasts from
[ __ ] Macedonia I don't even know
where the [ __ ] it is Macedonia that
sounds like some [ __ ] [ __ ] that got
washed away by the ocean the [ __ ] is
that's something a part of the world
Republic of Macedonia set near
Madagascar I only know Madagascar cuz
they made a [ __ ] cartoon about it
alright let's look it up on the map
please and I know a lot of you will
laugh and a lot of you don't you know
where the [ __ ] it is either was this
part of the Eastern Bloc now go [ __ ]
yourself you weren't even a goddamn
country when I was a kid no wonder I
don't know you you know what you guys
you guys are like an expansion franchise
the goddamn Jacksonville Jaguars are
[ __ ] older than your country your
crew we will call me I should go to you
before [ __ ] Stalin
well you lost your [ __ ] I don't give a
[ __ ] it's like it's like you fell off
the wagon it starts over again I'm
actually decent with geography you guys
won't believe me had to go start naming
some countries but you wouldn't believe
me cuz you think
looking at a map where the [ __ ] am I
going let me get back to the goddamn
podcast
alright let's plow ahead here umm
dilemmas dilemmas how far into this
podcast are we thirty one goddamn
minutes alright dilemmas hey bill do you
think you could run faster if someone
stole something really important from
you and you were chasing them down the
street or if you stole something from
someone else and you would be you were
the one being chased that's not really a
dilemma that's a great [ __ ] question
um that all comes down to what was
stolen from me or what I stole if I
robbed a [ __ ] bank I could outrun Bo
Jackson because I have that level of
fear of going to prison Bo Jackson back
in the day by the way if somebody stole
something really important somebody
stole my [ __ ] dog yeah I could
probably yeah I would save someone stole
my dog you know that would be if someone
stole something else I would give a good
chase for two blocks and be like yeah
I'll [ __ ] buy another one you know
that's not a dilemma okay number two
somebody gave me a great one this week
they said what would you rather do would
you rather what was that last week I
can't even [ __ ] remember somebody
said would you rather marry a stripper
and have your daughter become one no
that was last week right alright number
two would you rather be part of be part
start over bill just relax take a deep
breath would you rather be at a party
full of people you hate and have to
conduct small talk with every one of
them for the entire night or be on pot
on a public bus for an entire week you
have to eat your meals and sleep on the
bus and you can get off at the depot to
use the toilet yeah do you know what
that's a week of hell verse two [ __ ]
an entire night yeah that was an easy
one
listen really don't develop dilemmas to
sweet that was [ __ ] that was an easy
week be at a party I'm always at parties
full of people I hate I don't I hate
going to parties you know especially if
they're themed parties we're all gonna
dress up I don't want to do that [ __ ]
you know Gary then I was podcast yeah
where did it die where did it [ __ ]
die um advice you know it's funny the
douchebag of the week last week was
going it died with the dilemmas I told
you they suck
high-five yourself sir advice bill just
wanted to say I went to Carnegie Hall
and loved your show I'm new to the punk
is is and I would want your advice on a
lady that used to be a huge part of my
life okay here we go
so I'm a pasty white guy from the Bronx
and I went out with the Dominican chick
for five years during which I learned
Spanish fluently so I could speak to her
parents who didn't speak English see
that there you go there's an American
doing it cuz he had to and for the first
three and a half years of relationship I
fell deeply in love with her well he
writes what a [ __ ] you're not a [ __ ]
that's a good thing and respected her
reasons for not having sex during those
first three and a half years so skip
forward a bit I started thinking she
might be the one
then she graduated college and got an
offer to teach English in Japan first
off I don't know how someone doesn't
have a full grasp of the language
someone who doesn't have a full grasp of
the language herself can teach others
but that's for them to deal with so she
said it was only going to be for a year
and she wanted to stay together a few
months pass and she says oh god now dude
she's slowly breaking up with you
anyways a few months passes she says
they want her to stay another year and
that she wanted to go off on some hippy
trip to Africa so I told her to go [ __ ]
herself good for you
my question is how to explain to
everyone how much of a selfish [ __ ] this
Early's because for some reason everyone
thinks she's a saint
did you tell him the story she go he
goes I look like the [ __ ] especially
when that typhoon / earthquake /
Armageddon hit Japan last year and
people are asking me how she was and I
said [ __ ] knows maybe dead I [ __ ]
love this guy now this [ __ ] is coming
home after 3 years over there and won't
stop trying to contact me over Facebook
for some reason she can't understand how
selfish she was how do I explain to this
[ __ ] how [ __ ] up she is thanks for
your advice Billy boy
alright this is what we really need to
discuss here umm well how do you feel
about it do you still love her
alright if you do I don't know what to
tell you because she [ __ ] you over she
[ __ ] you over okay
you don't do that to somebody alright
I'm gonna go off to Japan it's only
gonna be for a [ __ ] year and you hang
around for a year and then after the
years up I'm gonna go to [ __ ] Africa
and go traipse around there that really
she really didn't want to come back and
see you at that point in your life and
now she's done you know sucking the
[ __ ] rainbow of dick she probably had
since she left you and believe me she
has cuz women don't count that over the
seas [ __ ] I think Chris Rock had a bit
about that which is so [ __ ] true now
she's coming back to you so this is this
is what this is what I'll tell you
alright
[ __ ] people who don't understand how you
feel about this girl [ __ ] them all right
you know how you feel about this girl no
I don't know how you feel about this
girl all I know is how you're telling me
you feel about her so that's all I can
go with you're telling me [ __ ] this [ __ ]
I don't like her anymore I want her out
of my life is the vibe you giving me
alright it sounds like she's content
to you on Facebook and you're having
conversations with her she keeps
contacting you which would indicate to
me that you still either have some sort
of unresolved anger you still like this
girl at which point you got to figure
that [ __ ] out but if you really don't
like this girl you don't like this girl
I'm telling you all right you gotta you
got to cut this girl out of your life
you can't talk to her on Facebook you
can't you can't have this girl come back
in your life that's what my guts telling
you can't [ __ ] this girl dude what are
you doing she just kicked you in the
[ __ ] balls pulled out your heart
showed it to you giggled in your face
and then went off to Africa to [ __ ] the
Zulu nation okay which is her [ __ ]
prerogative now she's coming back
alright
and she's contacting you again dude
she's like some [ __ ] sailor she's got
a different dick in every port and now
she's coming back oh no no baby how you
know don't be like that you know back up
her hand rubbing the side of your cheek
go [ __ ] yourself
go [ __ ] yourself she just wants a ride
to the airport all the way up to [ __ ]
167th [ __ ] Street under the George
Washington Bridge tell her to go there
herself alright with all their [ __ ]
world traveling money my gut tells me do
not get back together with this girl
don't alright there's other fish in the
sea and they don't go across the sea and
say that they're coming back and then
don't come back and then go over more
seas and then go [ __ ] some land fish
that didn't make any sense but you know
what the [ __ ] I'm talking about
alright come on man
step outside this [ __ ] look what she's
doing she's coming back to town it's
coming back to town like a [ __ ]
sailor she got to come in on a tall ship
with all those little [ __ ] hats on
[ __ ] that dude alright and she breaks
your heart again don't [ __ ] write to
me because you deserve it you don't
deserve it nobody deserves it but come
on alright that's what I would say he's
what do you say for some reason she
can't understand how selfish she was
that's because she sell
how do I explain to this [ __ ] how [ __ ]
up she is dude yeah look at you man
you're you're allowing her to suck you
back into her life
[ __ ] that this is how you explain how
much of a [ __ ] she was you stopped
taking her [ __ ] calls you stopped
taking her emails on Facebook dude she's
gonna [ __ ] do it to you again
like that [ __ ] does the [ __ ] Charlie
Brown
Charles M Schulz was trying to teach you
a lesson when you read those cartoons
that's what that host story's about
every time he comes in and kicked the
football and she pulls it away
Charles M Schulz was trying to say a
[ __ ] is a [ __ ] is a [ __ ]
all right but you just can't say that
back in the day you couldn't put that in
a newspaper number two bill I've been
hearing you [ __ ] about this is the same
[ __ ] this was also a known advice and in
diet tips Jesus Christ
all right overrated underrated for the
week all right
overrated taken off of taking off on a
Friday now that it's the end of the year
every one of my job has to burn off the
rest of their vacation holiday slash
personal days by the end of the year so
I checked the calendar and they are all
taking Friday's off granted getting a
day off kicks ass but isn't Friday the
best day of the workweek
oh that's overrated take them Friday off
isn't Friday the best day of the
workweek everyone's in a good mood
looking forward to the weekend and
you're sitting on your couch doing
nothing which leads me to underrated
taking off on Monday look at this guy
thinking outside the box good for you
good for you why is this not a better
option first Monday is the worst day of
the week you can get a shit-faced as you
want while watching footballs for 12
hours on Sunday but you'll show up on
Tuesday bright-eyed and bushy-tailed
this guy's got a great theory here it's
[ __ ] great besides when you will
hungover on Monday it isn't is it work
the last place you want to bleep want to
be plus not only did you get a day off
but you only got a four-day work week
ahead work weed ahead ahead of you
thanks to all my idiot co-worker
taken up all the Friday's I don't have
to experience a single Monday for the
rest of the month do that as awesome
this guy's a genius the added bonus is
that I get to listen to the Monday
morning podcast in the comfort of my
home instead of holed up in my office I
finally moved up from the cubicle good
for you sir now this is how you add to
your happiness
all right you find a girl who will
celebrate Valentine's Day on February
15th you know you get some drinking
buddies that don't want to go out on st.
Patrick's Day see what I'm saying yeah
run with the herd when it's good to be
with the herd all right but when they're
going over the cliff you just slow down
slow down stand to the side and watch
them all go over [ __ ] that
that's [ __ ] genius yeah Monday's the
war actually you know what I find is the
worst [ __ ] day of the week is Tuesday
Monday I was always so [ __ ] stunned
that my light you know what that was
with the realization that my life still
sucked like wow I really still work here
I was so [ __ ] stunned that but by the
time I realized the time I came through
was already lunch hour
it was Tuesday Tuesday when they were it
was the day when the reality of my
life's sunk in hang on the fence guy is
here and he wants to talk to me Oh for
[ __ ] sakes hang on a second everybody I
have to talk to the fence guy all right
now back the fence guy Jesus Christ I
didn't mention that I finally ended up
buying a friggin house out here you know
and you know nothing crazy I finally got
out from [ __ ] that crazy old guy I
was living above and then you get a
house you think okay no more crazy guy
no more crazy guy and then it just
becomes one [ __ ] thing after another
you got termites in your fence yeah you
got locusts on the roof okay you know
what the problem is
your hot water heater is leaking into
your dryer now I don't know did this
work before just tell me how much it is
well you see what you got here is you
have you have galvanized pipe up to here
and you have copper to here now I mean
it's up to you but the discoloration in
the water
Oh JJ the amount of times since I got
this place that I've been thinking of
the money pit and Tom Hanks watching
that bathtub go through the [ __ ]
floor uh what the [ __ ] you know that's
why I'm working three weeks in a row
everybody I'm back on the [ __ ] hook
back on the hook he's a working stiff a
[ __ ] fortune I do everything first
class though I don't know if you guys
know that I don't I don't buy a lot of
[ __ ] but when I do it I [ __ ] do it
right I pay somebody else to do it
[Laughter]
that's what I do and I got a good gauge
I got a good gauge whether I'm getting
[ __ ] it on you know first guy who came
over here he had that little a what can
I tell you today to get you in this
[ __ ] bathtub tomorrow he had that
vibe so he did he did one day work and I
was like go [ __ ] yourself
then I asked around to some other
homeowners and you know I'm gradually
assembling my [ __ ] a team here as far
as people you know it's fun though when
you have something [ __ ] up with your
house and then you just have people come
in and put bids on it yeah okay all
right what do you got what do you got
what can you do this for huh what do I
got to pay you you know but I definitely
I don't do that [ __ ] where I get people
who aren't you got to be licensed so I
pay more money but I'm not dealing with
I'm like you know he go down to the
[ __ ] Home Depot you know and then all
those goddamn refugees down there god
bless him
they [ __ ] work harder than I do but I
swear to God they will just you know you
should have seen the wiring in this
[ __ ] house I swear to god it looked
like
it looked like goddamn jungle and I
actually brought in an electrician who
was licensed and it was the funniest
[ __ ] thing cause he'd be underneath
the house in the crawlspace they know
basements out here so you got a
crawlspace is so he's underneath the
house like every 20 minutes I would just
hear them under the house going like are
you [ __ ] me you gotta be now would
just be upstairs laughing no one it's
costing me a fortune but it's worth it
cuz I don't have to be under the house I
don't know how to [ __ ] do it even if I
did I don't have to try and figure out
what the [ __ ] some unlicensed I mean me
as a goddamn novice I walked under the
house and I was going like you gotta be
[ __ ] kidding me I don't know what
that is but there's no way that that
isn't up to code
dude I actually had I went under the
house and I could smell gas they had
like two [ __ ] gas lines that weren't
properly capped it wasn't just openly it
was just sort of seeping out but
fortunately we get a great crosswind
here so we lit a fire we didn't [ __ ]
blow the place up but we had some
[ __ ] issues this is what I've learned
in the few months of having a house
having a house is like buying a classic
car you know you don't know what the
[ __ ] the last person did to it it looks
awesome you know but guaranteed you know
there's been a lot of donuts a lot of
burnouts some neutral drops and you're
gonna have to pay for it so I'm
gradually getting this place [ __ ]
shipshape so hang on a second why don't
I be a gentleman it hit pause when I
[ __ ] blow my nose that's what I'm
gonna do hold on so anyways yeah I'm
gradually gonna get this [ __ ] place
in in mint condition keeping it looking
like you know the same way if I ever got
a classic car I would do it I would keep
it looking like an old car but you know
underneath the hood it would have be
like all that brand new [ __ ] you know
I don't [ __ ] know but that guy that
guy's relentless man we have like a
fence that I share with the neighbor and
it had termites in it I guess
technically it was their fence you know
when some termites come up from the
ground others have wings
like [ __ ] Jordan and they just fly
under your [ __ ] house oh my god I
don't want to talk about it so I think
we've alleviated the problem this
[ __ ] guy's gonna come and he's wiping
out the whole fence he's putting down
this other kind of wood that I guess
termites don't really like I don't [ __ ]
who the hell knows I have no idea all I
know it's gonna be a brand new [ __ ]
fence and everything that gets fixed is
one less thing I have to fix although I
have I've done some of the [ __ ] I did
all the locks
you know that's not true I had a guy
come in and he taught me how to do the
locks and I did some of them he did the
others but I've been going down and
going down to this hardware store and
they got these you know we got those old
fashioned handles so the spindles are
really basically stripped on a lot of
them so I've been gradually were [ __ ]
replacing those starting small you know
whatever I tell jokes I'm good at that
[ __ ] so I'm not gonna [ __ ] up my own
goddamn house so what I'm saying is I'm
gonna be coming to a city near you
sometime soon sometime soon because I
got a [ __ ] house to pay for now I got
a nice healthy level of debt I'm helping
keeping the economy rolling speaking of
which what are you guys doing for New
Year's yeah would you like to go to an
unbelievable comedy show I bet you would
are you in the San Francisco Bay Area
do you got a lady who wants somewhere to
go come on out I'm gonna be up there New
Year's Eve I'll be performing in San
Francisco California and I will not only
me will be on the show also the
legendary Dave Attell star of the new
hit show on Showtime
Dave's old porn so it's Dave Attell
myself
the Daily Show's
latest superstar al Madrigal one of the
funniest most original and [ __ ] great
dudes
by the way the guy who hooked me up with
my electrician and co-host of minivan
minivan men podcasts al Madrigal will be
on the show and I know what you're
thinking like Jesus Christ that's almost
too much show who else could be there's
no way they could they could somehow
shoehorn another's major Talent what do
you think you think you're playing with
kids Hill here no we actually have the
sensation it's gonna be on the show for
those you don't know who the sensation
is the teen idol sensation from the Opie
and Anthony program ladies and gentlemen
the one and only Joe DeRosa fresh from
his stay at the Malibu Rehab Center he
was a little you know you suffer from
exhaustion once again he's been released
from his contract over at RCA and he's
got a brand new hour of material and
you're gonna be seeing about 20 minutes
of it Joe DeRosa the man born in a row
in the wrong time you know you ever
watch those old [ __ ] Hollywood movies
that are in black and white and
everybody walks around with the skinny
ties and they're slapping girl's on
their asses in office and they drinking
scotch you know that's the era Joe
should have been born in but the thing
is is Joe lies to himself and says that
he would have been one of the cool guys
but the reality is is he would have been
down in the mailroom looking like Jerry
Lewis in the Nutty Professor but don't
tell him don't tell him that let him
live that Sinatra fantasy let him walk
around with his Dean Martin haircut
you know his caddy let him do that let
him live the life and have a good time
he's gonna be there and I know what
you're thinking well that's got to be it
bill there's no there's no other way
that they got another comedian on that
show also well we actually do
Philadelphia's own the storytelling King
the Intercontinental Champion from 2003
to 2005 big Jay oakerson big Jay
oakerson
never blackjack mulligan I used to go on
stage was it hacksaw I don't know the
[ __ ] is there the guy used to go on
stage but the piece of 2x4 that dude
actually stole that from Jay oakerson
Jay oakerson used to go on stage you
know in one hand he held the microphone
as he wheeled his wielded his comedic
magic and in the other hand he actually
had a piece of 2x4 and it's just the
kind of guy who was and no one
questioned it you know he just looked
like you know we all love Jay you know
he has these always reminds us of sort
of a white trashy or Bob Seger I'm just
kidding all those guys are [ __ ]
they're awesome all right what did I
just say I'm just kidding like you
actually thought that that was serious
I'm just trying to say that's gonna be
an unbelievable show and it's gonna make
the Nob Hill mass Masonic center I know
everybody in England is laughing because
they call each other nobs I think that
means you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] we're at
the [ __ ] Hill Masonic center for
those of you in England people here in
the States were at the Nob Hill Masonic
Center in San Francisco California one
show only New Year's Eve get your
tickets that going fast and then I take
two weeks off before I go out I'm going
to Houston Texas on January 20th
I'll be at the House of Blues and and
I'll be at the Paramount Theater in
Austin Texas and this is basically
what's going down is me the redheaded
bearded face douchebag because I'm
getting ready to do another special that
I want to be taping March 3rd in
Washington DC and a yet-to-be-named
theater unless somebody already named it
I'm gonna be getting ready to do another
hour of stand-up and I'm doing a little
redneck tour to get ready I got dates
coming up in Charlotte I'm replaying the
stardome Theatre in Birmingham Alabama
and then I'm doing a theater in Atlanta
and that's right around February 9th I
gotta get those dates up on my website
then I'm coming back around and doing
the Fox Theatre in Connecticut the
Bergen PA see in Englewood New Jersey
I'm gonna be going through everywhere be
doing some shows in Los Angeles Westbury
New York everywhere
I'm gonna be getting ready to do my next
special so please come out support me
but as of right now come out to Nob Hill
whatever the [ __ ] it's called the Nob
Hill Masonic Center for that New Year's
Eve party of stand-up hilarity all right
we have the link up at billboard.com and
I think that's the podcast for this week
I believe that's it I hope all you guys
enjoyed it I hope you all have a great
week a wonderful Merry Christmas even
though I know you're not supposed to say
Merry Christmas I always say it Merry
Christmas you know so me Jewish says
Happy Chanukah to me I don't get
offended I know they don't mean in a bad
way when I go to Hawaii and someone says
hello I mean not hello they say [ __ ]
Aloha I know they're just saying hello I
don't get mad and Busey what's up that's
what we say that's less offensive so
that's it and as always people do you
need a last-second gift for Christmas
please buy Patrice O'Neal's elephant in
the room
if you need a gift just to get somebody
you can pre-order Patrice O'Neal's mr. P
on iTunes I can't stress that enough
the response to this has been
overwhelming and like I said the money's
going to his wife his mom his
stepdaughter and they are overwhelmed
with the support everybody's showing so
please keep doing it it means the world
to me that you guys responded the way
that you did and please keep doing it
like I said it's on iTunes mr. P I've
already listed some of the tracks I also
pre-ordered it I can't wait to hear it
and when you get it please tell all your
friends about Patrice O'Neal because
people have to know how funny that that
guy was you know what I mean that's it
you guys all have a good week go [ __ ]
yourselves I'll talk to you next week
and if anybody's got some got some good
football picks please send them to me
and Paul virzi because God knows we need
the help considering we're owen 7 at
this point all right see
you